You racist!
You're racist.
They're all racists.
It's all over the media.
You heard about it. Right?
And I'm so sick and tired of it,
I wanna puke!
Most people out there,
white,
black,
brown,
yellow,
purple,
or whatever.
Are not racists.
And the politicians, they love to use the racism card to gain power, and support.
And then, The media comes in and they love to shout it from the rooftops.
Because they know if they talk about racism, they will get views.
And It supports their agenda.
But here's the truth.
Most of it are lies.
They're poisoning our minds, and most people don't even see it.
Especially, the young people.
Look at all those rioters in America.
Most of them, young people.
Destroying and stealing from good hard-working citizens,
that are trying to make a living for their families.
We don't have a racism problem.
We have a criminal problem!
We protect the criminals, and we blame the cops, for trying to protect us.
Are you kidding me?
You're hearing and seeing more, and more of the slogan defund the police.
You know what, I don't hear with all of these calls to defund the police?
Is a plan B!
So who will you call, when they defunded dismantle police?
So what would happen, if we got rid of the police?
Of all law enforcement.
Things would fall apart, instantly.
People will die, if this is implemented.
What is?
I mean really?
Is anybody thought..
This is so absurd!
I can't believe we're even talking about it.
We have an authority problem.
We have a brainwash problem.
So let's check the facts.
Here's the key.
Eliminating the police does not mean, eliminating authority.
There is always authority.
And all of you walking around with black lives matter, and the organization.
Please listen.
Because yes, of course black lives matter.
Of course.
And so do all other lives.
All lives matter!
So let's check the facts.
Because the lies are, that cops kill more blacks than white.
It's a lie.
They also say, that it's racist attacks.
That's another lie.
They tell you that cops are racist, and must be reined in.
Most Americans don't agree with that.
That's not the experience they have.
In fact, police departments are one of the most trusted institutions, in the country.
We already know that the cops, are not just white cops.
Here's the facts.
In 2019, 370 white people were killed by police, compared to 235 black people in the U.S.
What?
You thought it was the other way around?
Well, yes, because that's what they tell you, right?
It's a lie.
Okay, Daniel. So what about earlier?
What about 2018/17?
Well, let's look at the facts.
In 2018, only 209 blacks were killed and 399 whites.
Yes, whites were almost killed, two times more than blacks.
Let's look at 2017.
475 White's were killed, and only 223 blacks were killed.
So that's more than double white's that were killed by police.
What, What?
Wait a minute.
So, why does the media not really talk about this?
Because it doesn't fit in with their narrative.
It doesn't fit in with their agenda.
Got that?
That's the nub of it.
The most privileged, are using the most desperate, to seize power from the rest of us.
Now, here's another interesting fact.
The total amount of blacks in America, are less than 15 percent.
And yet, they commit more than 50% of the crime in the U.S.
So, of course.
The chances that they will encounter cops, are more than the other races.
Right?
And why are most people so quiet when a black man kills another black man?
Or a black man kills a white man?
Media, why are you so quiet?
Because it doesn't fit in with your agenda.
Why are they doing this?
There are reasons.
Not the ones they tell you.
They tell you it's about racism.
They are not seeking racial justice.
What they are seeking is total control of the country.
Now, this is nothing to do with color, with the color of skin.
But everything to do with culture, and with a fatherless society.
You can do the research.
You can look into it.
If you're a criminal, no matter your color.
You will probably encounter the police,
and they have a right to put you in jail.
And if you are a danger to the rest of us.
Hard-working citizens that obey the law,
if you are a danger to us.
Then they have a right to take you out.
Now, I'm white.
I'm no racist, and I need you to listen here.
If 80% of all whites are criminals, then put them all in jail.
If 80% of all blacks are criminals, then put them all in jail.
The color does not matter.
What we choose to do with our lives.
Now that,
that matters.
Now, for all of you who live in America.
I wish we had your police in our country.
South Africa.
Where we have over 60 murders every single day.
We live in security areas where we have guards.
You can't drive with your window open, because they'll hijack you.
You have to have dogs in your yard.
We have 2 farm attacks in South Africa, every single day.
White farmers and also black farmers are killed.
They are tortured.
Blow tortures.
Hot irons.
They are raped and killed.
Sometimes hacked up into pieces, in front of their family.
Now, this is where your country is heading.
If you just leave criminals to do what they want to do,
and you put the blame on police and you protect criminals.
It means thugs are in charge.
The most violent people have the most power.
You have a huge problem!
When you start to call good,
evil.
And evil,
good.
Will there be bad cops?
Well of course there will be bad cops,
but it will be the minority.
Rest of the cops, they care about what they're doing.
They care about taking care of citizens.
They have pride in their work.
Will there be bad cops?
Yes, a few, but it's just like society.
There's bad people everywhere.
Are all whites bad?
Are all the blacks bad?
What about Asians,
Hispanics, and so on?
No, of course, not everyone is bad, but there will always be bad fruit, and good fruit.
But what will happen if we just leave the bad fruit?
if we just leave it out there?
It's gonna get worse, right?
And it's gonna influence the good fruit out there.
You don't have a race problem.
We have a sinful nature problem.
And there is darkness all around us.
So let's all stand together, and let's fight the evil all around us.
The evil in media.
The evil in politics,
And evil in us.
Let's stop making excuses.
Let's stop judging and jumping to conclusions, making assumptions.
Let's look at the facts.
All lives matter!
Stop calling me a white guy, and start calling me a human being.
Let's stop looking at colors.
Black, white, purple, whatever.
Let's stop, looking at colors,
And let's start to look at human beings.
And stop looking at the past, because you're keeping yourself a slave, in your mind.
You need to let go.
Break free.
Work hard.
Change yourself.
Because if you're not gonna do it for you, no one is.
Stop your excuses.
You in America.
You've got so many opportunities in your country.
Why do you think so many other people are trying to immigrate, illegally, into your country,
to work for next to nothing?
Because that next to nothing,
is more than they could ever have dreamed about having in their own country.
And please listen to me.
Most people out there still believe, that all whites are rich,
and they have more opportunities than most the other races out there.
It's 2020 people.
Stop living in the past.
There are many poor whites out there.
I grew up poor myself.
And our family, we had to work our butts off.
It was ingrained, into me to work hard.
Not just me, but our Afrikaans culture.
All the friends and family of my parents as I grew up.
It was something that all of us knew.
And they taught us, If you want to be someone someday.
If you want to have a good job one day, you better work for it.
It's not gonna be given to you on a platter.
Now, let's be honest here.
If you're lazy, you're not gonna achieve anything in life
If you just want to get stuff for free, not work for it.
Then, you're always gonna be poor.
You're also gonna be poor in mind, forever.
If you stay like this.
You will reap what you sow.
And yes, of course, there are some people who start off better financially than others,
but that's not necessarily really a good thing.
Some rich parents are so busy with trying to make money,
that they don't give their kids enough time at home.
They just give them money, but not love.
And then the danger is that they become spoiled.
You've heard the term before, right?
Spoiled brats.
And then when you look at poor families.
Who have love.
They are blessed, a lot more.
We have to change our way of thinking,
About race, money, all of it.
Because, we have a huge problem.
We are focused on educating the mind, a lot more, than educating the heart,
which is more important.
Think about this for a while.
In universities today, moral law is being thrown out of the window.
They teach that there is no truth.
Everyone can live their own truth.
You have your truth and I have my truth, and that is fine.
There is no right or wrong.
So let me ask you then this, professor.
What if that student,
what if he starts to believe you?
And he thinks, 'Man, there's no right and wrong.'
'I can have my own truth.'
'Alright, I'm gonna start killing people.'
And he goes to the school, and he kills people.
You can't tell him no, because you already told him there's no right or wrong.
So who are you or the police then, to tell him this is wrong.
Think about what you're doing.
You are creating monsters.
Like the monster, who killed a person.
Just because that person was standing in front of the shop that he wanted to loot.
While the killer screamed black lives matter.
Right is right.
Wrong is wrong.
The truth never changes.
Only our perception of the truth changes.
And in our hearts deep down, we know right from wrong.
We have a humanity problem.
We have a sin problem.
Nowadays, we can't even talk about sin,
but all of us are sinful, and we do sinful things that are evil.
And yes, there are some racists out there and that's also a sin.
So I want to call all of you out there
To stand up for what is right.
To stand up for truth.
Edmund Burke said,
"The only thing necessary for the triumph of evil is for good men to do nothing."
So, please let's clean up our society.
Let's love each other, because you can only overcome evil with good.
We are all humans.
We do no choose our color.
We don't choose where we would be born, in which country.
But we do choose how to live our lives.
Choose, right!